alors bon soir chantal hélène et michel
c bonsoir
très rare que je ne lance j'allais bien
je ne demande jamais ça je vous est
interloqué vous répondez pas
aux informations
oui c'est ça je rentre et je vais vous
dire la vérité je dis toujours la vérité
je te déconcentrer méchant train de lire
votre chronique chantal que je viens de
recevoir qui est toute chaude je crois
j'aurais pas le temps de la finir sur le
on a parlé la dernière fois qui est
francophone dans ce pays auront eu droit
à la fin de l'exercice à trois rendez
vous importants les uns entrevue
dimanche dernier tva demain je dis oui
demain et le débat du consortium le 8
septembre et vous explique un peu
pourquoi
c'est vraiment pour faire de
l'information de l'éducation populaire
parce que c'est le genre de sujet qui
décolle dans le style ils veulent tous
se mettre à genoux devant québec etc
alors c'était pour répondre à la
question comment ça se fait que ça
arrive c'est pas mal moins excitant la
réponse que le reste est très bien
ok c'est le modèle particulier
alors plateforme libérale plateforme
libérale
dévoilé on va écouter monsieur trudeau
puis on revient à paray
on est sur la bonne voie parce qu'on
était là pour appuyer les petites
entreprises pour appuyer les
travailleurs pour investir dans la
recherche et l'innovation
et c'est exactement ce qu'on va
continuer de faire avec un plan
responsable prudent est aussi
transparent les autres partis sont pas
en train de partager leurs chiffres
n'ont pas partagé leur à leurs
projections à part de dire qu'une pensée
magique que l'économie va croître à 3%
pour les dix prochaines années ce qui
jamais passé dans la dans la ville de
pays nous avons un plan concret et très
ambitieux
je donne les points rapidement la 78
milliards on va voir un tableau penryn
pour faire face à la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre ont dit nos garderies c'est une
réponse aider les femmes à aller sur le
marché du travail partout on leveaux
québec crédits aux aînés maintien au
travail aux personnes des crédits
d'impôt pourrait aider le maintien au
travail des personnes plus âgées et bref
bref le plusieurs éléments alors est-ce
que celle c'est
d'abord est ce que ces légendes annonce
qui est importante bien sûr qu'on
décortique tout se noue dans une
campagne il faut le faire faut que ça
soit jugée crédible mais les gens n'ont
pas laisse lire tous les détails de tout
seul
non ils vont pas additionner chacun des
chiffres se l'interdît ce que monsieur
trudeau 10 et je vais continuer à
dépasser pour sortir le pays de la
situation économique difficile qui a été
amené par la pandémie
mais en même temps on peut pas oublier
que pour 3 dollars de dépenses
supplémentaires que le gouvernement
propose dans cette plateforme lors dire
seulement 1 dollar de revenus
supplémentaires alors un moment donné
il ya quelqu'un qui va commencer à dire
il ya on va avoir un problème de déficit
à la fin je sais que c'est une course
vient d'ordonner la cote de crédit 3 au
canada mais il reste que 10 3 pour 1
alors qu'on a déjà dépassé du coup on
n'a pas de grippe c'est beaucoup c'est
possiblement quelque chose qui va
effrayer une partie de l'électorat la
question c'est de savoir ce que c'est
l'électorat qui est des jeux de toute
façon ma douche ou
bain ou non mes questions ils vont aller
se cacher parce que c'est paris notre
valeur avec un programme qui est pas
chiffré et avec beaucoup de dépenses
alors quelque part
le fait que les conservateurs arrivent
pas nécessairement toutefois au débat de
demain avec une date forme chiffrée il
ya beaucoup de dépenses dans cette
plateforme ça fait cher un autour de la
ja il va y avoir des semences déficits
et à part de dire je vais régler des
petits pendant dix ans
et ça le laisse un peu sentis secours
j'ai comme l'intuition qu'il va avoir
autant points à perdre sur l'absence de
chiffres de son programme électeurs que
justin trudeau avec l'idée qu'il est
difficile
on est dans une période assez
surréaliste en fait parce que d'habitude
en campagne et à la raison pour laquelle
on veut voir les cadres financiers c'est
qu'on regarde mes revenus proposer les
nouvelles dépenses proposées vont
regarder ça s'équilibre à peu près puis
qu'est-ce que ça fait sur le solde
budgétaire global mais depuis quelques
temps le gouvernement m'ont totalement
renoncé à retrouver l'équilibré
budgétaire ont même renoncé à se donner
ce qu'on appelle un ancrage fiscal c'est
à dire certains paramètres au delà
desquels on n'irait pas le côté
endettement et donc la surenchère est
permis n'importe qui peut promettre
absolument n'importe quoi mais milliards
de plus d'un milliard de moins ça fait
presque plus différence c'est quand même
une période assez surréaliste et est
aujourd'hui je pense que cette plate
forme qu'est ce qu'elle nous révèle en
fait avec ses 78 milliards de dépenses
supplémentaires c'est ça nous rappelle à
quel point le plan initial du parti
libéral c'était d'aller en élections au
printemps tout de suite après le dépôt
de leur budget qui contenait lui aussi
des dépenses pour cent à 1 milliard de
dollars le plan c'était de faire
campagne sur ces dépenses là mais leur
lieu la troisième vague on est obligé de
remiser le plan électoral le budget a
été adopté puis là on est pris avec un
budget qui comme un peu la vieille
nouvelle et on est obligé de trouver
autre chose pour faire campagne
ce qui explique les nouvelles dépenses
d'intérêts ça j'avais mentionné que
monsieur retour le chanteur a souligné
entre autres que monsieur retour pendant
ce temps-là refuse de chiffrer sa
plateforme de dire en fait exactement
comment en disant ils élimineraient lui
le déficit total ment on va l'écouter
on a un plan pour le rétablissement du
canada après la pandémie mais le père
giflant avec un plan dit qu'il est prêt
le coup le budget au cours de la
prochaine décennie on assume notre plein
immédiatement à pour le directeur
parlementaire du budget on a une jeune
un objectif d'une croissance économique
de 3% par année on va atteindre nos
objectifs nous sommes le seul parti en
faveur d'une relance économique dans
toutes les régions
et il propose
prod années d'austérité pour reprendre
le terme que les gens connaissent bien
ils virent pas de compressions même si
il nomma à la question ou comment vous
allez faire ils ne répondent pas du
temps mais il veut rassurer de ce côté
là aussi il veut pas non plus chantelle
et le champion de la non dépense
nécessairement parce qu'il ya pas dans
le moment un auditoire je convaincu
qu'il y en a la plupart du temps mais il
y en a pas dans le moment d'histoire
parce que pour ce genre de discours 2009
soyons sérieux quelque part en 10 ans et
la durée au pouvoir j'ai grandement dans
un parti au canada a fait ça on passe à
un autre appel donc je suis au tout le
pays un beau dire que dans dix ans je
vais avoir équilibré le budget ce qui
est possible les libéraux disent qu'ils
vont réduire radicalement le déficit
d'une année à l'autre entre maintenant
et finalement assez bientôt donc c'est
possible quand les dépenses pandémique
sont enlevées qui sont pas des défenses
figurants on se retrouve quand même dans
une situation où ça font rapidement mais
c'est facile de dire dans dix ans parce
que dans dix ans maintenant qu'on élit
monsieur autour du premier ministre le
20 septembre c'est pas lui vouloir du
mal que de penser que en 2031 peut-être
que ouais tour de table rapide à vendre
passion à refaire je veux parler de
monsieur x ils ne sont pas sport est de
la faute de trop nous mais michel c'est
sur une sur l'est les finances publiques
commencent à se jouer selon
le problème de bruit autour ne situent
aussi le club des vignettes rose
aujourd'hui le dit
une augmentation moyenne de l'économie
de 3% par année pendant les dix
prochaines années non seulement ce n'est
pas arrivé dans l'histoire du canada
mais aujourd'hui ça c'est canada dit
koné pour le dernier trimestre en baisse
et contraction de l'économie d'un moyen
pour ça alors d'une part s'est dit que
on peut pas assurer la croissance juste
milieu dépenses gouvernementales comme
chez tru dô thi puis d'autre part ça dis
que je suis au tour ces lunettes sont
vraiment bien teintées parce que on ne
peut pas à ce moment ci faire des
prédictions comme save the look et les
prédictions combo de l'avenir c'est
toujours risqué ouais hélène comme
envoyer la démarcation entre les deux là
monsieur o'toole nous dit qu'il ne fera
pas de coupure pour atteindre son
objectif
mais il faut quand même être un maître
sans attente en nuances il vaut quand
même annulé certains programmes
importants des libéraux je pense
notamment celui sur les garderies c'est
pour ceux qui le dit en début de
campagne assez de manière assez
alambiquée mais dites vous savez on a
cet objectif de ré de ramener ça à l'
équilibre budgétaire 10 a donc le
programme de garderies c'est 30
milliards 6 milliards par année à peu
près on n'a pas les moyens alors de dire
qu'il n'ya pas de coupure c'est une
chose mais de penser que toutes les
promesses libérales c'est ma télé
matérialiseront sous monsieur o'toole ça
c'est une autre paire de manches et je
pense qu évidemment il faut pas
s'attendre à ce qu'à ça arrive ceci dit
est ce qu'il ya un appétit pour parler
d'un peu plus d'équilibré budgétaire moi
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
chantal là dessus je pense que oui à des
gens qui commencent beaucoup à s'en
préoccuper vous savez pas très sont nés
tous les deux sur l'organisation du
débat on voit les questions que le
public nous envoie et s'il faut en
croire ces questions là un très grand
nombre d'individus qui sont préoccupés
par l' équilibre budgétaire et donc il
ya peut-être plus compense un appétit
pour un discours d'un peu plus sans
parler d'austérité mais un peu plus de
contrôle budgétaire de retenue très bien
passez pas vaccinale en ontario je vous
fais en tant que force n'était pas avec
toi début d'émission il dit dans le fond
c'est à cause des trous d'eau il rédigea
en faire un usage médical frère c'est
pas de ma faute je voulais pas/je résumé
c'est pas mal ça on est jeune on sait
que
m
chantal beaulieu de jeunes déclencher
une élection inutile il a dû faire pas
dupe vaccinale à ma place moi j'aime pas
sur faire ça dit
capable toutes les provinces s'attendait
à ce qu'il fasse ça c'est drôle on ne
pas entendu françois legault qui passe
pas son taux est né un an quand le bus
de l'armée monsieur trudeau dire la même
chose
les anglophones ont une expression pour
cette déclaration de ce genre de
déclarations c'est la personne une
feuille de film pour dire que la feuille
est tellement petit qu'elle couve pas
vraiment la personne qui est en train
d'essayer de faire volte-face ce qui est
en train d'arriver en ontario j'ai pas
convaincu que ça va passer la rampe les
gens qui veulent un passeport vaccinales
sont nombreux en ontario ont peu
tendance nécessairement être
conservateur et les conservateurs la
section qui en voulaient pau va pour
être satisfaite par cette réponse là
cela dit je note que monsieur ford et
peut-être bientôt monsieur cannes et
commencent à ressortir de leur tanière
avec les sondages qui montrent que ça va
plutôt bien pour le renaudot
oui bah écoutez il ya une autre
expression en anglais de devo mai 2002
où est donc monsieur to dubai al fassi
est petit c'est un argument un peu
étrange je voulais pas qu'il le fasse je
voulais pas en faire donc c'est obligé
d'en faire je pense que ça tient pas du
tout la route il ya quand même quelque
chose et j'élargis un peu la question
ici mais quand même quelque chose
d'intéressant avec monsieur trudeau
notamment aujourd'hui de dans sa
plateforme électorale qui qui va
protéger les employeurs qui voudraient
instaurer la vaccination obligatoire
certains en ont parlé à québec aussi qui
semble avoir cette idée là de vouloir
instaurer la vaccination obligatoire
dans les lieux de travail
autres amabilités à tout le moins ouais
ouais ouais et je me pose la question et
éventuellement si tout le monde
embarquer dans le bateau est ce que ça
veut dire que les personnes non
vaccinées nous n'auraient plus le droit
de travailler du tout au canada il ya
quand même une question qui mérite
d'être posée à cet égard une expression
mais je ne vous dis aujourd'hui non j'en
ai pas comme ça mais je note que c'est
aussi sur d alice cette affaire notre
transport d'apport de monsieur paul que
le surréalisme budgétaire dans lequel on
est moi je voulais pas faire un mais je
pensais que trudeau à l'enfer ça n'a pas
de sens et je pense que pour les
électeurs ontariens moyens monsieur
monsieur x continue de s'enfoncer et
c'est ça qui est le problème il est
peut-être sortir de sa tanière parce que
les intentions de voix de son bailleur
bon monsieur o toole mais lui ces
évasions de watteau pas l'air de
s'améliorer beaucoup qui dresse un temps
pour un dernier tour de table tva demain
présente son face à face
il y aura le débat la semaine prochaine
en français et anglais chantal ya encore
de la place pour on voit que ça bouge en
deux jours ça bouge à bord sa bouche de
l'eau rien n'est joué rien n'est joué
j'entends les débats ont néanmoins eu
tendance à en verser ou à accélérer des
tendances et c'est pour ça que tout le
monde demain un besoin d'un bon débat ça
va pas extraordinairement bien du moule
pour le bloc québécois le npd
peut-être que ces essais cessé de la
glace mais ces deux-là gassmann type
mafieux trudeau on n'en parle même pas
et rien ne tourne vraiment besoin de
compter des points au québec wen
oui mais monsieur signe sa voix bien
semble-t-il dans le reste du canada mais
je pense qu'au québec les carottes sont
un peu cuites pour lui ça va être quand
même intéressant de voir la performance
à la fois de madame paule la chef du
parti vert et de monsieur o'toole qui
sont les deux nouveaux sur le plateau
ah non excusez moi c'est vrai que soient
les moi je
moi je parle de 12h pour autant des
gens commencent à nous tous oui surtout
le défi quand même cessé de montrer si
l'état n'est parce qu'il est tellement
script est jusqu'à présent de très
beaucoup de difficultés à sortir de
celle du v6 donc les détails sont pas
tous temps lol alors ça ça pourrait être
difficile pour lui au débat celle ci
vaut attendre demain
ce débat l'oeil est important parce que
sa présence chez o'toole donne change se
présenter aux québécois les gens comme
ça qui est bien sport vraiment les
autres sont des quantités plus connus
mais c'est aussi important au canada en
guest des voleurs parce que s'il est la
même à peine c'est écrit dans globe and
mail ou d'enlever le winnipeg free press
que quelqu'un a gagné ce débat là ça
fait réfléchir les autres pauvres est
que les canadiens ont aucun intérêt ce
qui se passe au québec quand vient le
temps d'élire un gouvernement national
sait s'ils voient quelque chose se passe
au québec qu'ils ont des choses d'avoir
un gouvernement qui est puissamment
majoritaire avec ce parti doit donc
c'est pas juste pour
les coquilles
ou danton tous tard pour les ou deux ça
ça ce ne sera pas moi
merci à 23 pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne i see
her dit